let's go to Thomas from
um Thomas from Vietnam I believe is that
right Thomas
um yes how are you how you doing
uh fantastic fantastic uh being a big
fan of your show for over a year now
thank you you're you're what what kind
of a phone are you calling through
because it is a very strange sound
I'm I'm using a xiaomi beautiful
right
um so I have two questions
um the first one
um
um concerning the Republican party with
the with the current state of the party
you'll see who will be the one who could
you know like actually turn around the
party
and make it less of a you know uh
atrocity than it is now I you know
there's there's two ways to think about
that yeah what Republican could get the
Republican party out of trumpism one
school of thought it is that it has to
be a tried and true Republican someone
like uh you know Mitt Romney or
um some like the return of Paul Ryan for
example has been talked about in that
bucket Eileen more towards something
like the return of Paul Ryan would be
one possibility for getting maybe the
Republican party out of trumpism in a
slightly credible way the other path
would be a new Young Cadre of
Republicans that are very different than
the trumpian ones so not like mad Edison
cawthorne not like Lauren Boberg that it
that it should come from the Youth of
the Republican Party the problem is the
Youth of the Republican party from what
I'm seeing are suffering from some
pretty weaponized disinformation so I I
I think that if you said to me Paul
Ryan's the type of guy who could maybe
pull the Republican party out of
trumpism I might I might go with that I
might at least think that's a plausible
idea
well well I think we put five students
do or wait and see how it goes
yes we certainly
um my second question is
comparison because I'm
I noticed that recently in Vietnam the
there's been a current import of
trumpism and also Q Anon to a certain
extent uh because we we are we are
rolling out uh that test
um nationally but there are a lot of
anti-vaccination uh uh movements are
going under the radar
and it is connected with with you know
Trump supporters also connected to a
certain extent with multilateral
marketing as well uh so a lot of this
this you know Community with with cold
life kind of activities
they are being like
put together uh in in this sort of of
conspiracy theories anti-vaccination
kind of thing so in your opinion how do
we break that up I I don't know how we
break it up but I love that you're
bringing up multi-level marketing
because there is actually a big overlap
between anti-vaxxers and the types of
people that fall for mlms
uh and who often there's mlms that are
pseudoscience so it actually is not
shocking to me that you would have MLM
people who think that essential oils and
who the hell knows what will cure
conditions thinking that they don't need
to take the vaccine so I'm sorry it's
happening in Vietnam I am going to let
you go because the connection is getting
worse and worse by the second but uh
that the connection between MLM and
anti-vax genuinely does not surprise me
that actually makes a lot of sense